so as i'm sure you've heard on the 21st
of february 2022 vladimir putin has
officially recognized the new year's
gale host people's republics this is in
violation of international law and the
minsk agreement the letter russia
insisted on upholding while accusing
ukraine of not doing so following this
the russian military has entered the
donbass officially and with death the
separatists have stopped shelling
ukrainian territory for now at least
this is the official start of the
russian invasion of ukraine its extent
from now will depend on what putin wants
and of course how effectively ukrainians
can resist at the time of making this
video the 22nd of february 12 pm central
european time the russian army has not
yet launched any major offensives and
things seem to be quiet however this
will most likely change in the near
future the immediate next step i see is
the extension of the occupied
territories by a force possibly to the
entire don lunch regions and the
decision about this will be made in the
coming days after which further invasion
of ukraine might begin this will most
likely entail shelling the ukrainians to
either force them to retweet or
retaliate if they retreat the russian
army can just roll in and take territory
rinse and repeat until they have the
entire donbass if the ukrainians
retaliate that will likely be used as a
castle's belly at which point the
russian invasion proper will begin and
this will likely include simultaneous
attacks from the black sea from belarus
and from the east now all this being
said i'm convinced that this was on the
original plan and what we see in front
of us is a rather hasty plan b by putin
he most likely didn't actually intend a
war not originally i rather he wanted to
use the threat of invasion to strong-arm
nato into making concessions banking on
the fact that peace and stability are
more important for nato than ukraine
this however turned out not to be the
case the western response was united and
consistent basically calling putin on
his bluff at that point putin did not
have much choice since he's been
posturing war for months a retweet would
be a major loss of faith obviously after
which russian military threats would not
be taken as seriously so russia had to
go ahead at this point essentially just
making [ __ ] up along the way accusing
ukraine of suddenly wanting to invade
the donbass in service of this some
hasty false flag attempts have followed
which were bordering on ridiculous
russians claimed ukrainians shot rockets
into russian territory then they said
ukrainians destroyed a russian border
checkpoint but of course anyone with an
iq above room temperature can see the
problems here according to russia here
once they pull their troops to the
border and threaten with defending the
local russian population that's when the
ukrainians suddenly decide to start
provoking them a country with the
world's most nuclear weapons and an army
five times the size right very cool then
russians aired footage of supposedly
ukrainian troops assaulting yet another
russian border checkpoint but
fortunately and conveniently for russian
media they apparently recorded the
entire thing on a gopro or something
right then separatists claimed
ukrainians blew up the core of one of
their leaders as it was standing in an
empty parking lot with nobody in it
right and then there was a claim that
ukrainians blew up a gas pipeline in the
lewis region also that they are shooting
at the civilian electrical
infrastructure showing a picture of a
single torn wire with some smoking
vegetation around it so once again
according to russian propaganda
ukrainians did not invade the dumbass
for 8 years of conflict but they wanted
to do so now when russia pulled 150 000
troops to the border threatening a
full-scale invasion under the pretext of
protecting russian speakers alright and
the reason why all these false flags
were so half-picked in my opinion is
because as i've said this is a hasty
plan b and a solid clue to this is
putin's hour-long disjointed borderline
unhinged rambling about ukraine
following the recognition of the
separate hysterias where he persists to
invoke ethno-nationalist justifications
between incoherent historical statements
the effect of russian invasion wasn't so
clear cut from the beginning there was
certainly some power play around the
russian government as there are
influential people within and without
who aren't necessarily in favor of
invasion for example the russian
military elite would not be too happy
with the concept of losing thousands of
russian soldiers in an invasion against
a supposedly fraternal country sanctions
are also a factor not just for the
economy as a whole but also for the
russian business elite and while russia
has built up massive financial reserves
over the years eventually sanctions will
start to bite not to mention the
presence of those reserves will hardly
be felt by ordinary russians social
issues can and will lead to instability
which pushing cannot afford so the way i
see it putin has basically trapped
himself in this situation if they stop
now all they'll have achieved is making
the separatist regions official which
they controlled anyway but those are
also economic black holes with destroyed
assets and infrastructure with most of
the population gone and for this they
get sanctioned and turned into
international pariahs not to mention
nord stream 2 which is now suspended
indefinitely and putin can't really
backpedal at this point this was his
rubicon and he crossed it aliyak daest
as they say at this point the only
potentially beneficial choice for putin
is to press on and try to achieve his
strategic goals within ukraine this
includes the land bridge to crimea
severing ukraine from the black sea and
as a worst-case scenario annexing the
entire country up to the carpathians but
these options also present their unique
problems for russia ukraine is currently
experiencing warmer wet weather meaning
the ground couldn't freeze enough to
allow quick passage for armored vehicles
and the north and east of the country
during the thaw are practically
quagmires this negates the possibility
of a blitzkrieg meaning the defenders
can better prepare and potentially do
more damage to the russian army
struggling in the mud also as a rule of
thumb attackers tend to lose more troops
and equipment than defenders western
provided weaponry is also a major
problem ukraine now has all sorts of
advanced hardware which can do serious
damage to russian hardware so even
though the russian army is larger and
more powerful the unfavorable terrain
the defender's edge plus western weapons
risk inflicting heavy casualties on
troops whose morale is not that high to
begin with this is not crimea it won't
be a short bloodless campaign followed
by celebrations it'll be a long bloody
conflict leaving thousands dead waged
against a fraternal people in service of
the russian elites interests russian
soldiers stationed in ukraine are
treated rather badly to begin with the
moscow time is describing it as
nightmare conditions and these russian
soldiers are facing motivated defenders
with high morale hell bent on protecting
their home from invasion this would also
be russia's first large army logistical
undertaking since 1945 against a modern
mechanized military which is also a
first if they [ __ ] up at any point or if
ukrainians manage to sabotage their
supply chains enough things can go
downhill for the russian army rather
fast so as you can see things aren't so
straightforward for putin as one would
think in fact a worst case scenario
would be them taking severe losses due
to unexpectedly high resistance supply
chain problems sabotage and so on thus
the high casualties leading to severe
domestic instability back home which
then cascades into more logistical
problems for the army and loss of morale
which increases losses even further
rinse and repeat until russia simply
collapses under the weight of the crisis
it created and then the fun stuff begins
such as ukrainians taking by crimea and
the dumbass and the like this is of
course a less likely scenario but it's
likely enough to cause concern for putin
especially now that his approval ratings
are lower to begin with so this is my
informed guess about the situation it
could be that i'm wrong but so far
things seem to be lining up for example
the luhansk militants declared today
that as far as they're concerned the
entire luhansk region belongs to them
and of course they called on the
ukrainian army to pull back so yeah in
the meantime don't forget to like and
subscribe and i'll be seeing you next
time